thirteen years ago a young man drove
into a neighborhood parked his car and
vanished his family Desperately Seeking
closure more than a decade later
Savannah's video captured what are
believed to be Stephen kosher's last
moments alive a news now investigator
David charn's reviewing new clues in the
search for Stephen David well it is
truly haunting video 30 year old Stephen
kosher walking through this Henderson
retirement community never to be seen
again so where was Stephen going who is
he meeting and why was his phone pinging
off a tower miles away days after he
disappeared
what did you see in that video if if
that is Stephen
that he's going somewhere with a purpose
you're watching the last time 30 year
old Stephen kosher is seen alive it's
December 13 2009 a surveillance camera
catches Stephen driving into this
Henderson retirement community minutes
later at the strike of noon Stephen
walks in and out of view where he is now
is a mystery he's always just just a
kind person Dal and kosher has never
given up finding his older brother who
was living in St George Utah at the time
and try a new start Stephen volunteered
in church was learning to play guitar
and was trying to make some money
washing windows it would have taken a
lot in my personal opinion to for him to
have planned all this out to disappear
and Without a Trace I was trying to make
it on his own that was the biggest thing
James Burke Danny Livingston and Kevin
Wyatt are private investigators working
to find Stephen there's no there's not
one shred of evidence that suggests that
Stephen did this to himself or that
Stephen walked away their case starts
before that video before Stephen
disappeared records the 8 news now
investigators obtained reveals Stephen
was three months behind in rent and I
think Stephen had some debt that he
needed to clear up and someone made him
an offer
um and he took it probably not knowing
what that was and it resulted in his
disappearance and what we believe is his
death in the days before his
disappearance financial statements put
Stephen in Saint George then Washington
Utah then near Overton Mesquite and
finally in the Las Vegas Valley on the
day he disappeared he didn't have any
money so he couldn't afford to drive
back and forth so he's doing something
for someone but there's no record of why
he ended up here what's he doing in an
upscale over
55 neighborhood that home surveillance
camera catches Steven's car driving down
Savannah Springs Avenue at 11 54. he
Parks his car at the end of the
cul-de-sac this photo showing how police
found it abandoned Days Later inside
gifts for his family frozen food a
pillow and a blanket Steven was coming
back to that car Steven then walks up to
a house on the street where a witness
claims he said this he says hey do you
want some cash
the private investigators suspect what
happened next led to Steven's fate
Steven leaves the neighbor's house
rounding the corner at evening Light
Street toward the house where they
believe Stephen was making a delivery
the private investigators have this
Theory I think he went to the home that
he was supposed to go to and actually
says oh kind of funny I told the guy to
ask him if he wanted some money I think
that's what resulted in Steven's
disappearance was that error and then
there's this clue the investigators
obtaining these photos from inside a
home in the neighborhood taken shortly
after Stephen's disappearance it's the
same property where they believe Stephen
was heading in those final frames on
video we have photos of a of a
room that was destroyed
at about the same time so is that based
on struggle of fight and a death is it
based on a struggle a fight and a
kidnapping is it based on somebody who's
just mad I don't know while Stephen
vanished on December 13th his digital
footprint lived on he and or his cell
phone was moving around
um whether he was alive or not the next
day someone called Steven's voicemail
box the phone's signal continuing to
Ping off a cell phone tower near the 95
and Russell for several days until the
device died 13 years later Stephen too
is silent for me this is a what's called
a missing body homicide
and
law enforcement needs to start over do
you think your brother's alive so if
he's alive and he knows who he is I have
a hard time imagining he'd he would just
be be gone and and stay away from our
family Dallin kosher says he's accepted
the fact his brother may not be coming
home I honestly don't think he's alive
anymore he has this message if Stephen
is out there if you're watching you know
we
there's always a spot here in this
family for you and has never closed and
it never will close
another St George police nor Henderson
Police have arrested anybody nor have
they filed any charges in connection
with Stephen's disappearance Henderson
Police declined to talk to us for this
story saying there were no updates for
them to provide if you have any updates
for them you can do so anonymously by
calling Crime Stoppers I'm David charns
8 news now Brian